doesn't know where they're going to be
in 10 years from now and if they get if
Microsoft gets to a point yeah Microsoft
gets to a point where they don't
realistically need the place let's say
called let's say that the the Call of
Duty thing works the way Xbox think it's
going to work and they start draining
mad people from PlayStation right and
then it gets to the point where six
seven years down the right Xbox is way
has way more market share because
they've had a lot more of the market is
for Call of Duty and then it just gets
to the point where they're like look we
don't even need ourselves anymore that's
where I mean just if you're a Microsoft
from a business standpoint do you walk
away for free money just for it existing
on a base that's larger than yours you
don't really work with it don't make
sense and to be honest for The
Regulators this is a key point to help
them get the deal to tell The Regulators
hey we're letting them have it they
don't want to sign the deal for whatever
reason but we telling them you're gonna
have a parody you're gonna have it on
your platform